the uh buccaneers as we mentioned at the
very top
in the process of systematically keeping
the band together close to re-signing in
dominic and sue to another one-year deal
very interesting to see what the terms
are because sue is the example we've
used from time to time to illustrate how
the middle class a veteran player with
recognizable name could get squeezed
dramatically in this year with 25
million less in cap dollars than what
there would have been in a normal year
stars get their money a lot rookies get
their money not much guys in between the
ones who get squeezed and someone told
me back in
december january when it was really
coming into focus that this was going to
be a down year guy like and dominic and
sue is not getting eight million he's
getting three million in this new
environment so we'll see how many
million what are you doing who adds to
his career earnings i don't think it's
gonna be three i don't expect that i
think it's gonna be north of six that
would be at least my my bottom line
there well you think that's correct
here's my prediction yeah it will
initially be reported
as in the neighborhood of seven to eight
right and once we get the real numbers
it will be something less than that
with the opportunity to make up the
difference based on playing time getting
to the playoffs
per game roster bonuses whatever the
case may be because rob gronkowski's
deal advertised as 10 right not 10. this
is not an uncommon thing this year or
any year but i think this year
especially
when you have a higher degree of
of ego bruising for some of these star
players who aren't accustomed to not
making all that much and it's very
common for agents to inflate what these
deals are worth
i think we're going to hear that in
dominican sioux
has a base package better than what it
actually is whatever the numbers yeah
eight million is what we're told ends up
being six and he can make two more or
something like that so
i so assume that up to is part of
whatever the initial report is as to
what dominican sue makes because i i
just think that
even though they've created a bunch of
cap space with some some of these other
deals that doesn't mean that
that and dominican sue is the one who's
going to consume it you can save that
cap space for some of these other deals
you have to do for your younger players
who are moving toward contract number
two vita veya is already eligible devin
white is going to be eligible after this
year right you got to save some of those
cap dollars and every cap dollar saved
now automatically goes to a future year
so that doesn't mean you just burn it
away for a guy who maybe has one year
left in the tank yeah right i mean it's
coming down to the end it doesn't need
to i mean because i think the play on
the field justifies like you look at it
and you go uh he could play a few more
years there's no doubt about that it's
not like a guy we're looking at where
i'm going oh it's it's coming in the end
you know i think we think like what you
just said mike just because we figure
hey it's a rough and tough position he's
been playing it for a long time and i do
think he's got a little bit of like if
he's not in a super bowl type team or
making the amount of money he thinks he
deserves he'll walk away but i'm amazed
i'm amazed by the bucks and just
everything they've done i mean the fact
that they got this all orchestrated kept
the players
and good for them i mean really they're
in it right now it's there to be had
they can make a super bowl run once
again we know i mean just as bruce arian
said that that clip there
there's there's not really a weakness to
the football team and now they kind of
we saw them come together as a team and
kind of get on all on the same page
and
sue is still a force
you know when you break them down and
watch them on the defensive line not
that he is the star he was five six
years ago
but you know what does happen is he he
probably loves playing in tampa because
he gets a few more one-on-ones than he
would in other places because the people
exactly right so people are worried
about those other guys and i think
that's why you know last year uh what do
you have six sacks which is like as high
as he's had since 2015 or something like
that so that that i think speaks to you
know what we're saying there those
one-on-ones those opportunities and he
does bring an attitude to the defense
you know that's the one thing i like
about adama consuming dominican soo has
not been one of those defensive players
mike who's like slipped into the
you know i i don't know i get annoyed
sometimes when defensive players are too
smiley and happy and help quarterbacks
up and do stuff like that he's still old
school he's still trying to intimidate
you he doesn't care if you're aaron
rodgers or whoever you are he wants to
help them down he'll he'll put you down
right he'll throw a right hook at
patrick mahomes face i mean we saw that
he will he doesn't care and i think
there's great value in that in this day
and age in the nfl too
well there's a line there that you don't
want to cross yeah he's been on either
the wrong side of it or stepping on it
literally from time to time during the
course of his career but i like the
point that
in tampa with those other great linemen
around him he's no longer the guy who
gets doubled and tripled he's the guy
who's getting the one-on-one matchups
and he's able to have a freer run
at the quarterback or the ball carrier
or whatever it is his assignment
requires on that play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports